(instrumental guitar music)
- [Dr. Jenn] Is being
told what to do something
that bothers you in
all areas of your life?
- Is this happening now?
- When you are in a room with me,
therapy is always happening.
- Damn.
("Try Guys Theme")
- [Zach] Today we're doing group therapy.
I'm super amped on this.
- I've never been to
therapy, but I'll do it.
I dunno what it's about, but I'll do it.
- I don't really see the point of it.
- What could go wrong?
What could go wrong?
So many things.
- I'm Dr. Jenn.
- [In unison] Hi, Dr. Jenn.
- Welcome to therapy.
- Should we lie down on each other?
- You don't have to.
We're not doing Freudian analysis,
but I do want you to be comfortable.
- Lay on him.
I think therapy is super useful,
and not something that anyone
should ever be afraid of.
- So what do you do?
- I'm a shrink.
I do individual therapy, couples' therapy,
family therapy, and group therapy.
This is almost like work therapy.
You probably eat together,
you talk in between shoots together.
- We've slept together.
- We have slept together.
- There, you sleep together.
- Not the coolest kind, yet.
- Not the coolest kind.
- Yeah.
- The G kind.
- We're great friends,
we work together a lot.
We work together really well,
but I don't think we're perfect,
and I'm really excited to see, you know,
are there underlying issues?
- Why should I pay someone to talk to me,
when I could just talk to someone?
- When you sit down with a professional,
they're a neutral person.
If you ask your mother, your father,
your best friend, one of these guys,
everyone has their own
agenda in your life,
even if it's positive.
When you see a professional,
they don't have an agenda.
- What if I feel like
I'm doing really good?
I think I'm pretty perfect.
- I believe everyone has
room for improvement.
- Strong men talk about
their feelings, bro.
- I think a lot of people
think that I'm the most
conceited Try Guy, because of my hair.
I think Keith is the most conceited.
- I'm Keith, of the Try Guys,
A.K.A Justin Timberlake of NSYNC.
- We're on camera a lot doing bits.
- I hope people think I'm so
cool, I'm so down to earth.
- But a lot of Keith's funny stuff is
about wanting to be the
center of attention.
Almost to the point of
being kinda conceited.
- [Keith] The crowd just
screamed bloody murder,
just by being beautiful
Keith and the rest.
- And it makes me uncomfortable.
- Everybody's really talented in
Try Guys at what they're good at.
I think that my skills are probably
lower than everyone else's,
on the things other than performing,
so I play more into
the performance aspect,
because that's one of the things
that I do think I'm good at.
- Did you know that about him?
- No, I didn't know that about him.
I said something difficult to Keith.
He wasn't defensive.
He was kind of was very
introspective about it.
I think you are one of the best
performers, if not the best.
- You know, it's hard to bring up
a concern you have with somebody,
but I'm glad that he did,
so if it's something that I can
change, then I'll change it.
I think Zach should be more confident.
- I sometimes feel like I need to
say like three times as many lines as them
just to get one good quote in.
When I was a kid, I was
not good at anything else,
like, that's why I started
doing creative stuff,
and that's part of why I was depressed.
Like I hated doing sports.
That's how you're cool.
You're either cool 'cause you play sports,
or you don't play sports
and you're not cool,
so I wasn't cool.
(announcer's yelling)
- [Voiceover] Weak
transition there out of Zach.
- [Voiceover] That's
gotta be one of the worst
transitions I've ever seen
on American Ninja Warrior.
- Zach has a tendency to be
really worried about stuff.
- I'm not a masculine
man, I never have been,
and I have no qualms about that.
- Are you like scared to get hit?
- Absolutely.
(gasping)
- Don't you have problems about that?
That's like, I would have
so many problems with that.
- What's the alternative?
- When you say, you know,
"I'm not that masculine,
I'm not that strong guy,"
I think that you're stronger than
you give yourself credit for.
- I think he gets in
his own way sometimes.
- I'm never confident in
what I've done on a shoot.
I always just see the thing
that I didn't do right.
- When you obsess and beat yourself up,
it ceases to become productive.
Whereas you're able to take and go,
"Okay, this is how I grow as a performer,"
well then it's actually kind of
a good thing that it happened.
- Shit, Dr. Jenn.
(laughing)
- Ned should be more comfortable being
himself in more places.
- I'm a manager with a lot
of other responsibilities.
I feel like I don't always have as much
time to commit to doing Try Guys projects,
and I end up working extra.
- Balance I think would be good for Ned.
- So I talked about Keith earlier,
and I was thinking about
it more as we were talking,
and I think a lot if it stems from
me being pulled in a lot
of different directions,
both in work and family life.
- You're actually being a
role model to these guys
when it comes to being in a relationship.
- I am married.
- [Eugene] Ned is married.
Ned is married as fuck.
- My wife.
My wife.
I miss my wife.
We are thinking about having a baby.
I sometimes get anxious that I'm not
being as much of a contributor
to the group as I can,
and I have to compensate for that.
- Did you guys know that he felt that way?
- I mean, he's in a really tough place,
and I think it's really admirable
how much he's able to do.
- I'd like for you to
look at your schedule,
and kinda go "Okay, where
can I have some down time?"
Even if it's 20 minutes of vegging out,
you know, playing computer games,
or just like hanging out with your wife.
I think you need to start
inserting those into your life,
so that you don't resent other people.
- I have an ironic sense that
therapy is explicitly designed
for people like me who don't
have access to their feelings.
- We gotta push that wall down.
Eugene's gotta have his walls pushed down.
- You have a little bit
of a rebellious spirit.
- A little bit?
(laughing)
- Have you electrocuted
anyone's taint before?
- No.
- Oh my god, it's even worse now.
Oh this is the worst.
- I feel like you shut me out.
Eugene is one of the most uniquely
talented people I've ever encountered.
I feel like a lot of the time when,
you know, Eugene takes the lead on Ned,
he doesn't want our help,
and he doesn't want us to get involved,
and it's a little hurtful.
- Did you know he felt that way?
- I am aware that I shut people out
during creative processes.
- You could even be missing out
on things from these three guys,
that might make your
next video even better.
So you were saying that you
don't like to be told what to do?
- Yeah, I'd agree with that.
I have two sisters, where I
know we were highly competitive.
- [Eugene's sister] How are you so skinny?
- We can prove to mom I'm
finally the prettiest sister.
- Oh my god!
- But as a family, it's kind of like,
the underlying expectation was
just to be better than everyone else.
- It must have been a lot of pressure.
- Yeah, yeah.
So if I was gonna be the
artsy one, which I was,
I had to be the best artsy person.
- [Dr. Jenn] Yeah.
- Touch my hands.
- Why?
- Oh, they're sweaty.
- Your hands are really sweaty right now.
- Ew, ew, why'd you do that?
- 'Cause I don't wanna be here.
- That was awful.
(laughing)
- I get that the family you come from,
you're not used to talking
about certain things,
so it's uncomfortable to talk about it,
but my goal is for you
to leave here knowing
more about yourself
than before I got here.
- Blegh.
This is highly uncomfortable.
- I like that he had an insight,
and then immediately recoiled from it.
(laughing)
- I feel something, I just
don't know what it is.
- Thank you so much for trusting me,
and opening up to me, and for
being open to this process.
I appreciate it.
- Thank you, Dr. Jenn.
- [Keith] Thank you, Dr. Jenn.
- The scariest thing I
ever done, in this series,
is sit down with my friends and a woman
who is just intent on
knowing more about me.
Maybe I should just open up all around?
Maybe I should go to therapy?
- Hug.
- [Try Guys in unison] Hug!
- [Keith] Oh, that's Eugene's favorite.
Eugene loves this, he's
gonna be so excited.
Oh my god, he's gonna love to hug.
- [Dr. Jenn] Aww, thank you.
- [Keith] Here he comes.
- [Dr. Jenn] Thank you.
- I don't mind hugging Dr. Jenn.
No, I thought you were gonna
make us do a group hug...
- [Try Guys in unison] Yay.
(upbeat instrumental music)